should we have someone call Joe Rogan's
Comedy Club the mothership in Texas and
ask if we can do a Drag Brunch for kids
[Laughter]
that's one I would love to see yeah hold
on let me see if atomy the booker will
answer my call
right now on the air I think it's just I
think it's just a fun idea and let's see
if he answers
hey how are you I'm doing
how the [__] are you I'm good so let me
ask you a question you're you're on my
podcast right now I wanted to know if
it's a great Mothership comedy club in
Austin Texas we could do a dread brunch
for kids
yeah we're open to all you know
everything all Races Creeds I just just
run it by Joe just go someone approached
me about doing a Drag Brunch for
children but we give all the but
everyone's armed it's an armed drag
brush